David, how should we actually deal with police
brutality?
OK, in this segment, I'm not going to argue
about what percentage of cops are good or
bad or try to quantify the degree to which
police brutality and racialized policing is
a problem.
It is a problem even.
Listen, Rush Limbaugh said things that were
bought, you know, for Rush Limbaugh standards,
conceding that we have a problem with policing
in this country.
On The Breakfast Club earlier this week.
Kellyanne Conway said it now.
Kellyanne Conway also said and Trump is dealing
with it.
That's a lie.
I'm not going to argue about the degree to
which it's a problem.
It's a problem.
There are many issues with policing that need
to be solved.
It doesn't matter if ninety two or ninety
four percent of police are good or whether
it's ninety nine point one versus ninety nine
point three percent.
We've got a lot of issues that need to be
solved.
So here are some ideas from the point of.
So there's the legal side and there's the
behavior side.
Let's talk first about how police behave.
We need to be looking at training and a lot
of the infrastructure that's there.
So.
Police training in the United States should
be completely reworked for lack of a better
term.
If you look at many other countries, officers
train much longer before they are just sent
out to be police.
OK, now there are going to be arguments about
it costs too much.
I'm telling you what should be done.
Then we figure out how to make it happen.
And by the way, we found six trillion bucks.
I think we can find a way to better trained
police if we decide we want to do it.
Germany, as an example, trains police much
longer.
The United States, sometimes you've got like
a 12 or 13 week training program and then
you're out there.
Sometimes it's, you know, six months or whatever.
Police training needs to be longer.
And a lot more of the training needs to be
more the type of training that social workers
get.
Academic stuff based on the principles that
you would learn if you were studying for a
master in social work because you prevent
a lot of crime.
What it straight out just you prevent having
to deal with crime.
Then we'll get to how.
How do you deal with crime?
You prevent a lot of crime.
If you have police that are properly trained
as social workers, in addition, there's a
lot of stuff that's not actually criminal
or it's marginally criminalized as misdemeanors
that can or cannot be enforced based on the
discretion of officers, where if you have
officers better trained in de-escalation,
you have officers better trained with some
of these soft skills, as we might call them.
You reduce the number of interactions that
become problematic.
Number two, we need more extensive psychological
and personality testing of police, and we
want to just make sure we're bringing in the
right people.
Again, most cops are good.
Some, like Trump admitted on on Twitter, they're
looking for action.
There's a sort of bloodlust in some fraction
of police officers.
Those officers understand this.
And I don't I don't want to get off topic
here.
The bad apples, the bad eggs don't just typically
do one bad thing, they do a whole bunch.
So a huge portion of the over overuse of force
complaints and other bad acts are concentrated
among a small number of repeat police offenders.
If we did a better job of evaluating and psych
testing and personality testing police, we
could root out a lot of the problem by never
hiring that small percentage that wants to
get out there and slap people around and is
looking to get the riot gear and do what we've
seen being done on videos.
So root them out with it.
More psychological and personality testing.
There should probably be some established
process for civilian review of shoot police
shootings and uses of force.
It can't just be left to police departments
to investigate because we all know that there
are many police chiefs that are doing this
properly.
We know that there are internal internal affairs
boards that are operating more or less OK.
We should probably have more civilian involvement
in review of police shootings and uses of
force.
We've got to demilitarize.
The militarization of police forces has been
a huge problem.
I've talked about that on its own, so I won't
delve too much into that.
And there should probably be a national database
of bad police actors because it would prevent
two things.
Number one, there's a national database of
of bad actors, people, police officers with
a high number of complaints against them.
It would prevent officers from hiding prior
complaints by simply not reporting them when
they're trying to get hired.
A new police department, because there would
be a national database of reporting to the
database, should be mandatory.
But also, if you're hiring a police officer,
if you're not bringing them through police
academy and you're giving them their first
police job, it should be a requirement that
police departments have to check with that
central database so that the police department
can't get away with saying, we didn't know,
we just didn't know because it would be a
requirement to report complaints to the database
and to look at the database.
If you're hiring someone now, then you've
got prosecution in terms of prosecution decisions
on prosecution of police officers and the
prosecution itself, meaning the trials, it
should be happening ideally outside of the
county where the incidents took place.
It can be very difficult to get what we would
all call a fair trial.
Fair to the victims, fair to the officers,
fair to everybody, fair to the community when
a lot of these cases are being tried inside
the jurisdiction.
Now, by the jury, you might be outside of
the town, but still in the county and in a
lot of America, that's not far enough.
That's another thing that should should be
done.
You've got to try and prosecute these cases
outside, realistically, of the county where
they took place.
Some ideas.
There are many more.
I'd love to hear from you.